[Music]
everyone in Grandmaster Denis borscht
and this is kramnik over the years like
is it is in shik and in style to look at
games of past legends I mean obviously
chronic is still much alive just like
Michael Jordan so right here let's take
a look at games from different periods
of Kramnik and see his last dance let's
get into it
so this first game is going to be played
against Shirov where he's actually
playing but black and you'll be shocked
to see that in this first game where she
relays efore and when kramnik was still
in his young teens he wouldn't go a 5
wouldn't play and Eve wasn't even
dreaming of the Berlin wasn't even
thinking about the path trough he
actually was a wild Sicilian player so
the player you see today just was the
contrast his young self alright so let's
go into this game these six nine six six
d6 Bishop g5 one of the main lines of
the Sicilian the classical Sicilian I do
call it the rift arouser earlier days
Bishop c4 was played he's six Bishop III
Queen c7 Bishop b3 a6
Queenie - and this is famously known as
the vellum Maravich attack with long
castle g4 g5 and plenty of Knight f5 and
95 sacrifices however Shirov was already
well educated and knew that Bishop g5 is
probably the victim
even though we're still in the 90s he
six Queen d2 Bishop e7 now recently the
young stars has picked up Richard Robert
weapons of a six F for an Bishop d7
which was by was played by me as well
against Fabiano Caruana so Queen d7
Bishop e7 this is the other line however
not as popular as the a6 Bishop d7
system is still played by legends in
fact this was played by none other than
a Gary Kasparov against Karpov long
castle takes takes a six so here black
decides to get rid of that d4 Knight
because in many of those Karpov Kasparov
games that I mentioned before with a six
there's 93 and then you transpose into
these typical English attack positions
which according to the practice can be
very dangerous for black so here kramnik
took on d4 as a precaution between d4 a
6 f4 and b5
black is not afraid of this 'if i push
and if that happens why can't just take
on e5 takes takes and if fe seemingly
this would win a piece however it does
not because there's 97 and if you take
King takes d8 the King will hide on
these seven and the e5 pawn will become
a real problem over there so seeing this
sheer of avoids be five and takes Bishop
f6 if you're new to this whole complex
of the reefster browser you would think
that ah you're going to take on f6 and
have the bishop pair as compensation for
the pawn however according to practice
that's not quite enough you can try but
usually
you are suffering however G takes f6
which is a very strong move in this
position is the main way to play in this
Richter rouser black gets the bishop
pair however will get weaknesses all
around the King we should be too green
85 now Bishop e2 even though at first
sight seems a little bit pointless it's
pretty venomous actually the idea is
Bishop h5
so if white that is I mean black if
black does not pay much and pay much
attention there could be Bishop h5
pressing on that f7 pawn and if f5 ever
comes F takes c6 will be forced to take
with the bishop because you're pinned so
let's say rook b8 have 5 mu G it you are
forced to take with the bishop but in
that case there's no one really to guard
the d5 square and black is strategically
lost so knowing that this position is
actually very dangerous for black but at
those days in the 90s Kramnik like to
live life dangerously played Queen a5 a
tricky little move Bishop h5 if you
might ask doesn't really work
there's b4 and that long-range sniper on
a5 would capture the bishop or the
knight on c3 that was the big trick
however
Shirov as we all know always goes for
broke
there's no difference here he goes for
e5 realizing that blacks King still in
the middle and potentially endanger
thinks it is due time to open it up for
the rook and the Queen now that square
is still heavily guarded as well as the
d7 square so it's not immediately the
size
if F takes and takes d5 so let's stop
here just for a second Oh d5 and observe
so Clinic has a decent position Black
has a decent position because he has
more central control white has one
measly pawn there but it's sort of
isolated sin long-terms
black is the one with the advantage why
because he has the bishop pair and once
the Queen's are gone the e5 pawn will be
a potential target so long terms this
position can be very good for black
however when we talk I like say Shirov
we know that they're gonna be fire on
the board so here he plays his signature
move Knight takes d5 and I think c5 is a
dangerous move but kind of played in a
tall fashion it's not entirely correct
however very dangerous to face now here
kramnik actually doesn't have a choice
if you don't take that 9 you can just
resign as after Knight f6 or even I take
c7 you are down upon with a really bad
King so you must accept the gift be 6 so
if Queen takes d5 and just would be 8
and there as mentioned before there are
no mates on the 8th or d7 so black will
survive the attack also if you go here
rook F 1 black just castles
and after that Bishop e6 is going to
solidify crime next position so II six
was played instead and now this is that
typical position where it shows if you
have a gift for this game or not would
you play f6 what would you play here
let's think about this a little bit
leave yours take your chance to think
have a deep thing here give you a minute
so what grandmasters do is the following
they say oh my opponent really wants to
crush me on f7 also they want to take my
rook that's not a good deal I can't take
on any six because of that I've rook
would fall that wouldn't be great well
if I move this pawn then they check me
take on d5 and my position is in rooms
not fun because yes there's no mate yet
however all of these black pieces are
dis coordinated so what to do the young
Kramnik said let's castle seemingly
insane castling inside the attack and
just facing the wrath of device pieces
but Kramnik is not afraid
rogue d3 just saying okay i'm fine of it
the checkmating you as bishop takes c6
we're running to rook g3 and it's faith
it's literally checkmate takes check
here
checkmate not much you can do about it
however Kramnik has this little sneaky
check his sleeve
what's the point well it's a check we've
got to move the king black is winning
some time here also robbed g3 won't come
with a check and black won't get
checkmated immediately now if white does
get rue cage rook g3 and h4 and quickly
enough it is going to be checkmate so
Kramnik says okay i don't care about
pieces no more I'm just gonna activate
this bishop and connect those rooks so
believe it or not even in the wildest
positions basic principles still hold
true
rogue G 3 8 6 H 4 so Shiro is kind of
anticipating that this position is gonna
be fine as all of his pieces are
mounting pressure on this King what can
go wrong there are certain things that
can go wrong namely with this h4 move a
certain piece got a little bit loosened
and that is the g3 rook Queen c7 hitting
that rook and now it's going to be again
the series called 24 who's faster can
black actually stop the attack in due
time
well you don't have to ask shear off
about this he is obviously gonna take g5
and say hey I'm gonna take on 86 and I'm
80 on h8 what are you going to do about
this
but as I said before Kramnik does not
care he takes that look like it's not
even there
locate 6f6 now if you check that doesn't
really do much there's Bishop d1 and you
can't bother that King that much anymore
also you don't have extra moves to get
active because as mentioned before you
just get checkmate it just played f6
just closing in rook g6 check now which
way to go you go this direction that
direction one of them is good the other
than less so less
in fact the big move is engage seven if
you go king f7 you're probably gonna get
nightmares after this game because
that's what Queen takes f6 King e8 Queen
takes c6 not only you're going to lose
the whole house
you're even gonna get checkmated because
you just don't have enough folks around
like here check here check here and the
checkmate
so one bad move and it's gone so it's
pretty important here for Kramnik to
find the King h7 the reason I then go
can gauge it because at times rook F 6
can be annoying because you go here
takes oftentimes this roca can go
backwards and still check the king
Kramnik really didn't want to take that
risk so goes King gate 7 putting the
King on a light square check King g7
again cold-blooded
if takes then this King would take this
rook on age 6 and as we all know you
cannot really
checkmate a king let alone Queen she
went rogue f6 now he give this Queen e1
chick so but is forced to defend Brooke
f6 be enough 6 King g8 in g6 can get
fate here and after king e8 [ __ ] of
designed because Kramnik actually
defended valiantly and after king d7 the
rook comes into the game and then she is
just down the hall rook so in this game
what you saw was Kramnik defending
getting into somewhat of a sketchy
position but holding it together that
those brilliant defensive moves such as
Bishop g5 check the big highlight of
this game was Bishop g5 check
not only winning time but closing this
rubgy 3 file I mean gee file and 86
Queen c7 just noticing with this H move
this rook actually becomes a little bit
destabilized and after that it was
relatively easy for Kramnik however
still a nice defensive effort by the
young Kramnik but talking about
legendary vase kramnik played in the
2000 to 2010 he kind of switched to a
more positional style where he was more
focusing on positional plusses and
positional squeezes so let's take a look
at this legendary game that he played as
a white versus Vishy Anand so no
surprise in those years he really liked
to play the Catalan with great success
Castle DC Queen c2 this was the main
line then and this is still the main
line of the Catalan a6 now these days
people like to play a for stopping this
b5 maneuver but in the early days they
said it's not a problem it's just going
to be a weakness b5 between c2 Bishop b7
now by at this moment you might know the
moves but they have an idea behind it so
the fight in this whole Catalan system
and the main line that is fight is
revolving around the c5 square whoever
well on that square is going to either
equalize or get the advantage
so if white is just a dilly dallying a
lot and let's see 5 happen actually
black gets a really good game as often
times this Bishop is just better than
the g2 1 and it also has a little bit
more space so instead the opening
geniuses came up with the idea of Bishop
d2 a very weird move if you're talking
about development what is this Bishop
doing on d2 when it could get to some
nice squares on f4 and g5 well the point
is the following normally black wants to
go a 97 place c5 however if you would do
so now there's Bishop a5 and you
wouldn't want to give up a queen just to
play c5 just yet if you go and I'd be
six again it'll be very tough for you to
ever to play c5 and like would just go
90 to 93 and get a decent position as he
will get the control of that square
however Anand is a legend himself and
plays rule k7 the idea is the following
black doesn't want to show his hand just
yet so if you would go Bishop a5 now and
there's knight c6 hitting this bishop
yes blocking the pawn but getting rid of
that bishops if you move back then there
is night b4 takes takes and after that
these positions with the bishop there is
a fairly decent for the black player
therefore here kramnik played a very
thematic move and a very nice one can
you spot Kramnik very nice prophylactic
move it's not your typical developing
move
so night c3s would be so great
because the whole fight is still about
the c5 square so if you go here black
would just go Knight d7 no more Bishop
a5 threats and then the next move black
is gonna play c5 and be super happy if
you go before that would fix the
structure and create the weakness there
however it's not developing and the
pawns might get a little weak especially
after Knight c6
hitting both the b and d pawns
so here kramnik decided to play rook c1
kind of emphasizing that hey I'm still
attacking your c7 pawn also I'm bringing
more guys to over defend this c5 square
it should be 4 that's kind of the point
of route k7 just defending this rook
from the sides Queen b3 and here you can
see that actually crammed mix plan
triumphed why because if you go Knight
d7 still Bishop a5 shows up on the board
and you'll never get c5 in so black is
forced to play knight c6 however it's
not the tempo the big difference earlier
on was that after knight c6 white was
losing time moving the de bishop however
in this position black had to play
knight c6 without actually winning time
knight c6 III and if you can't mend time
you're actually just blocking this c5
idea III Queen a8
however Anand is known to be inventive
and he is trying to put some pressure on
that g2 Bishop so you can't really jump
around just yet Knight c3 would run into
this beautiful sacrifice of Knight takes
d4 if you take on d4 Bishop f3 and today
black is just up upon and if 94 there's
just Bishop g2 mblaq is just better
so here kramnik came up with another
very nice positional maneuver a
positional rush if you will so let's
ponder here what could be kremlings big
idea in this position just think about
the fact that this g2 bishop is a little
bit loose also that knight on f3
ican Kramnik over defend all of those
things
now my t1 would make sense however with
every exchange black would be happier
why because black has less space and if
you have less space usually you're kind
of happy to exchange as many pieces as
possible also after 94 for example there
could be some pressure on that bishop
sometimes even Knight g5 Knight f3 so
this can get a little bit uncomfortable
for kramnik not wanting any of that
problem played this pretty nice
positional move of Queen d1 at first
sight this looks a little bit strange
but it does move away from 94 tactical
tricks which would hit the Queen also it
over defends the f3 Knight 98 not so
much a defensive move but a regrouping
black is planning to play Knight d7 and
c5 also pressuring the afternoon night
but as this Knight moved back kramnik
played and took his chance to play
Bishop a5 and Bishop e5 is actually a
dual-purpose move not only does it
attack the c7 pawn it also threatens
this maneuver of 90 to 93 which would
put a big grip on the c5 square you
can't really play c5 because of Bishop
d6 ideas and you lose the pawn Shawn on
was forced to play rook c8 now c6 could
be an option however this looks kind of
ugly as the Queen would be disconnected
from the bishop Luke c8 a3
another little waiting move just asking
what are you going to do next
Vichy so let's see five there's still
Bishop b6 you still face some problems
if you go Knight d7 then you might face
problems at b4 Bishop d6 but first off
he played 92 again making sure there'll
be no funny business on the f3 square
Bishop d5 and noticing that there's
still some tactical ideas on this g2
bishop he plays this peculiar move of
Queen f1 which is a very strong move
mind you no more e5 tricks like if Y
could have played before there could be
a 5 surprisingly and if D takes e5
Bishop takes e5 and that that black
would gain some bit of a freedom if you
take on e5 this Bishop takes g2 and
black is doing all right
however after Queen f1 black is box then
still can't play c5 cuz we should be 6
and I take your pawn on c5 and other
than that you are just out of brakes you
don't have c5 you don't have any 5 and
black is just stuck you all move 18 and
Anand is out of moves 97 and se5 is no
longer such a big threat he plays B for
stopping the most important break c5
look at those pawns actually controlling
that all-important c5 square so now I'm
seeing that there's the last chance to
do something active goes for e5 and here
comes a new dilemma those who I really
want to engage in a fistfight over
five square or not so if you don't fist
fight for the e5 square well you are
inviting it takes d4 to happen that some
exchanges and if you ever take with the
night let's say rugby one takes takes c5
actually becomes an option as there no
more pawns blocking of that square and
if c5 is successful Vichy will get a
good position might even be a little bit
better because potentially he has an
extra pawn which might become a passer
later so seeing that kramnik decides to
take on e5 instead Bishop takes e5
Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 and cram
next next move is again very nice very
unconventional yet positionally sound so
if I would ever have a positional rush
this would be high on my list very very
very high so White has the bishop pair
but cranek realized something even
though I have the bishop pair I have
pressure on my opponents position let's
see seven pawn as a target it's not that
easy to move forward but he also
realized yes I do have pressure but
other than that these pieces are just
scattered and not doing too much so came
up with this brilliant idea of building
a wall of pawns just blocking of this
whole diagonal rendering both the bishop
and the Queen useless so place here f3
not a good move in any other position
but here it's brilliant why he is just
going to build a wall of palms and then
black will
nothing left just to wait and see how
chronic is going to crash through on the
C file also note that there are no more
ideas of Knight f3 trying to exchange
pieces which would you know at least
ease the pains that black has in this
position so after he was played stopping
any kind of jumps and remember there's
also more pieces left on the board which
favors the side that has more space
Knight c4 again in the same way Anand is
trying to exchange pieces 9 c4
Bishop c4 be enough - now here's like a
little bit of a dilemma and question so
some of our new players or like players
in the 2020s or like late 2010 and later
they might consider sacrificing on c4
however kramnik developed to be a very
technical player when he sees an
advantage and says hey I have the bishop
pair I'm about to build a big Center why
would I risk my advantage and give up an
exchange when I could be better with all
that so even though some of the guys
influenced by computers would take and
say that this might be just better
because I have the bishop pair you're
struggling cronic says I don't not need
those adventures I have a better
position why go that far Ruki 8e for the
master plan is complete the Queen is
completely shut off this Bishop has no
targets also black is still struggling
with that c7 weakness place c6
however Anand did achieve something he
blocked off the C file that the bishop
and Kramnik not wanting to exchange this
bishop he wants to keep the bishop pair
goes on to
new pastures and goes on to play on the
D file Luke t71 exchange rook d1 now you
might be asking me will d7 but why did
they exchange pieces right here
well Kramnik realizing that okay I have
a better position I've got the center
black has no pawns in these four squares
that kind of guarantees an advantage
also he controls that d8 square which
will come into play later Center rug d7
normally you do not want to exchange
pieces however man Kramnik exchanges
their plays rook d1 he realizes that for
that exchange he gets the D file the
only really important file in the
position so if he could get these pawns
rolling to f4 and e5 put pressure on c6
and control the D file this would be
what we call a positionally winning
position beam b7 rope d6 again a very
nice touch and you can start thinking of
playing f4 however that would give
counter chances for Anand hitting on e4
and afteri 595 and no longer it is that
clear how to win this position because
this bishop is useless as but already
has lost the control of the D file and
the knight on d5 there is not much Mike
can do either he's going to win that an
attack or not gonna been at all so
seeing that he plays rugby 6 first
planning to get the Queen to d4 and
putting pressure on the d7 tonight that
way and also kind of preparing this f4 e
5 idea compare this position to the
previous one at least you have a rock
inside blacks camp and after Queen c5
there'll be targets on c6 which you
wouldn't have when your rook is still on
the one so these little
details matters so much when these super
grandmasters evaluate these positions
rook d6 seeing that f-4e 5 is coming
Anand played f6 just making sure 'if
I've never happens
f4 just building this new formed Center
also targeting the c6 spawn live and
eventually five sometimes life could
even sacrifice the pawn and then take on
c6 rookie six and here comes the motion
Kramnik actually doesn't want to
exchange pieces the only reason he
exchanged pieces earlier on is to get
the default you're just gonna drop back
to d2 saying I do not want to exchange
off your terrible rook which has no open
file and can't even get to the default
because my bishop is controlling that
square and our black is basically just
waiting for kramnik to finish it off
rookie 7 Queen d4 putting all of those
pieces on the d-file sending up some
ideas of Queen d6 just pressing on that
book and maybe coming up with E 5 pushes
so non plays 9 f8 just over defending
everything and that's actually
high-class defense by Anand just his
only issue as the opponent has played
near perfectly so far talking about
anons defenses made sure that
everything's defended and that white
will have to work hard to win this game
and that's already a result that could
be enough against other 2700 s but not
against Kramnik so he mates gets the
Queen they're probably even preparing
some rugby sick
ideas or sometimes even Bishop b6 Bishop
c5 and if that ever happens it'll be
just game over rook d7 rook d7
I mean takes d7 takes takes and here
comes the big blow so what you see in
these games are the following
kramnik only goes for simplifications
man he's a hundred percent sure is going
to work in his favor so you might have
guessed that that chronic already has
something up his sleeve man he let on on
exchange off the rook and the Queen I'll
give you a little bit of time to think
about it that's pretty sure you can
sense the right move in this position
so the big targets on a sex and see sex
but it's hard to get close to them and
if you can't can't if you can't really
get close to them
positionally well you might as well use
tactics 'if I've and that is kind of the
quintessential Vladimir Kramnik he is a
positional player and the 2007 to let's
say 14 and but if he needs he still
plays tactics he gives up the pawn just
he can get close to those weaknesses and
e5 is decisive here you can't really go
Bishop d5 because you'd exchange and
allow a passer for white and that's just
completely losing for Anand sanam takes
bishop takes c6 but with this night
being loose you can't even go night b8
because we should be seven bf/gf and you
can't really stop Bishop c7 at all and
after that d6 pawn is just falling and
then an extra pawn plugs the bishop
there like is just completely busted
Knight f6 this should be seven Sun on
just gives up on the pawn trying to
conjure up some counter play yep GF 95
King f2 kramnik is not interested in the
f-bomb he's only interested in these
future passers Knight f4 King III the
king is the strongest piece of the angle
and if it might stroll up to b6 it might
be decisive g5 but first off he takes
that pawn on e6 do you have seven now
this could be a useful plan but because
of this unfortunate placement of the
bishop on c4 there's a four played by
Kramnik you can't ever capture because
Bishop takes c4 and the beat pawn is
fast and you're down apiece
so a for King g7 this should be five
takes takes and this is probably already
pretty bad because not only does white
have a passport but it's an extra pawn
and it's a bishop versus a night hanging
and if you're familiar with bishops and
nights you know that Knights really do
prefer to have a battle on one side of
the board instead of two sides and with
pawns being on both sides this is very
very advent very very good for Kramnik
King b7 Guinea for so what Kramnik is
doing here putting pressure threatening
to promote while also trying to take all
of those King side pawns 92 this should
be six just activating finally that
Bishop which was sleeping on a5g4 Bishop
f2 and this is important very important
move by kramnik he's making sure that
anon cannot exchange of the H pawn if
that would happen he could get his King
to b7 and hold the draw so Bishop f2 was
crucial for this game Knight c3 can get
five takes king g4 in g6 King g5 can you
have seven can get five so now he has
this double threat of going over to the
Queen side so none goes King g7 and
after Bishop c5 he resigns because
either he goes this direction tried to
stop the beep on but then white it just
goes and picks up the H fondant the H
bone will promote or if the King goes to
the f7 and tries to defend the H pawn
that way then King g5 King d5 and king
c6 is just winning as that pawn is just
unstoppable mind you even if kramnik
gives up this pawn for the night that's
also winning because adds
the correct square for the c5 bishop so
this was one of chronics nicest
positional wins so that is kind of a big
change from the 90s kramnik where he
went
all-in for complications instead went
for the more solid ways of playing but
fast forward to his last candidate again
he did a 180 going back to his 90s style
of chess and that game is between
Kramnik versus Levon Aronian let's take
a look at that one so in this game
already kramnik is out of contention
however earlier on his new style almost
gave him a ticket to play magnus carlsen
however he did lose a crucial match and
he was leading I think by one and a half
points in front of Khurana but lost and
because of that he kind of fell out of
contention and his adventurous thought
somehow it didn't fit the candidates but
anyways back to this game here you will
see his new style that he kind of
acquired he's going more in the
adventurous route instead of the
positional Kramnik he v 9 f3 knight c6
earlier on everyone played Bishop b5 but
since then they had issues with the
marshal and the Berlin sin this game
kramnik chooses the Italian Bishop c5
and Knight c3 now Knight c3 is a funny
little move played here by Kramnik
everybody now plays b3 and c3 however
Knight c3 is saying I am going to play
an e4 e5 system however I'm going to
play it like I'm black so when I have 6
d3 a 695 share of used to
sheriff maybe Sheriff but mostly short
used to play Bishop g5 h6 takes takes
Knight d5 and c3 trying to play with d4
breaks
however Kramnik is looking for new ways
of playing this position and he goes for
this fairly rare move of 9595 Bishop d5
d6 Bishop e3 so basically what Kramnik
does here is he is actually playing this
position like he is playing with black
so he's playing a reversed Italian
Bishop e3 he's just trying to nullify
the scope of this Bishop Bishop takes c3
now Levon could have just canceled and
accepted the structure however he is in
a fighting spirit and he says you'll get
the F file however you'll get double
pawns for that castles castles and here
Aronian does what he does best
creative chess now most everybody would
go 97 96 and yet a fairly reasonable
position as this pawn chain is defended
and nothing much would happen here but
LaVon is famous for that creativity and
known from the Brier he chooses to play
98 obviously he is not setting up for a
new game he's just be organizing his
troops and plans to move this knight to
f6 via b8 d7 and then to f6
but this is probably the most creative
game of the candidates as Kramnik says
hey you can't play creative moves oh I
can't - and plays b4 now B for buying
itself doesn't seem particularly amusing
however he does gain some advantage and
some space on the flank so he is trying
to stop
black from building of all of bonds with
c5 d6 and 85 97 Queen d2 so there's no
rush yet everyone is just developing
quietly c6 there should be 3 a5 a3 and
in some sense it is kramnik who's
playing and italian / spanish type of
structure with the bishop being on b3
like b6 and getting this typical Spanish
structure of a6 b5 which is kind of the
copy of a 3 B 4 Knight f6 not one thing
to say Bishop g4 he plays age three age
six rugby one again showing fighting
spirit saying I don't want to exchange
rooks I'm just gonna move my rook away
over a defend might be font and see what
you're going to do next
she played b5 could have played Bishop
e6 as well which would have lead to
fairly dull positions but they're both
going for more let's plays b5 mean c3
just been pointing that there's some
weaknesses there on c6 Bishop d7 and
here kramnik comes up with a very very
nice little plan now there are many many
attacking players who would go and slash
and burn just as it happened in the
first game between Shirov and Kramnik
however cranek likes to prepare his
attacks so try to channel your inner
Kramnik prepare your attack in this
position
so obviously white wants to put pressure
on the F file however night h4 would run
into this beautiful tactical trick of
Knight takes e4 not only your knight is
hanging but also your queen you go de
Queen h4 and you're just lost
seeing that Kramnik decides to embark on
doubling it goes rook f2 preparing a
rugby f1 and then planning to go on at
age 4 Knight f5 or even sacrificing on
f6 v b6 trying to stop this rook from
getting to f1 rook e1 rook e8 but here
comes Knight h4 c5 so the vault is
trying to break through on the other
side while kramnik is trying to crash
through via the Kings side but c5 kind
of VOC the tiger inside of kramnik and
said okay rook f1 C takes b4 I don't
care about pawns no more I'm going for
sacrifices I'm gonna make you so seeing
that that is actually kind of dangerous
LaVon played the correct d5 move just
blocking the bishop a b de ba rook takes
a 5 & 9 IG 6 which is a very nice little
move not only putting pressure on e5 but
introducing rook takes f6 ideas Levon
played Bishop e6 Knight takes e5 he
takes d3 and here comes the bombshell
boom row cap 6gf rook takes f6 so even
though by this bounty exchange look at
them
pieces lurking around the king it's hard
to defend but as we shall see leaven
does a good job here place B to a very
nice little move trying to set up some
counter threats and that's what those
are the things that you should do when
you're being attacked and you want to
deflect all the other pieces from your
king queen g3 King f8 and now Kramnik is
forced to go back to work f1 just to
stop this cleaning now with Knight g6
being a big threat and I takes f7 ok7
was played by Kramnik cram next opponent
that is level defending that palm and
that is actually very accurate allowing
kramnik to give a check on g6 but
miraculously this is still fine for
Black Knight f4 can you shake night h5
but this is getting very dicey as both
of those checks could prove deadly
however in comes f6 they can await that
Square and defending the g7 square with
the rook Knight takes f6 rook f8 green
f4 locate 7 now there were some big
threats if you can't even clean because
there's just gonna be mate 187
and if you go King g7 there's a knight
h5 and you lose the whole house so rook
h7
even though super awkward it is the
correct move by Levon so if you think
about it loved one has been defending
for like 10 moves in a row playing the
best moves
but after Queenie 5 he falters and plays
Queen c7 can you spot the brilliant
finish by Vladimir Kramnik
Queen c7 seems like the normal move
however there's a trick that actually
nets crime like the wind
and that is the brilliant night e8 check
problem is you can't really go King g8
because Bishop takes c6 and you lose
everything and you can't take the Queen
because rook f8 Bishop g8 rook takes g8
one of those beautiful games beautiful
recent Kramnik attacking games that he
played and as you can see this is the
modern chronic that we know so he went
from very sharp player in the 90s as
you've seen in the share of game 2 a
positional genius to back to the
attacking Kramnik that we all love so
whenever you see kramnik play don't ever
expect anything positional anymore
expect fireworks I really hope you
enjoyed this lecture on Kramnik over the
years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you